pas question pour la caq de laisser le
champ libre à québec solidaire dans
sherbrooke ça nous prend
une carte exceptionnelle cette candidate
c'est caroline st-hilaire ex député du
bloc québécois ancienne mairesse de
longueuil l'envi de servir était très
fort et ça a réveillé quelque chose
alors c'est pour ça que j'ai accepté de
venir servir ici à cherbourg
elle affrontera la députée sortante de
québec solidaire kristine labrie fecteau
l'inflation la crise du logement est
environnemental dont on nous parle
la lutte s'annonce rude kristine labrie
a été nommé étoile montante par ses
pairs à l'assemblée nationale elle s'est
démarquée par sa pugnacité sur les
enjeux de l'éducation et la famille
quant à caroline st-hilaire sa
connaissance fine de la politique tant
fédéral que municipal est un atout
majeur qui la rend ministrables en l'an
2000 velde qui signe de vie omni dans
les versions de votre achat route une
des rares places au québec qui existait
on peut dire la coaltion avenir québec
mais là les intentions de viande
viennent de se référer sont maintenant
l'égalité peu connu dans la région
caroline st-hilaire aura plusieurs défis
devra démontrer première manquée elle
n'est pas parachutée elle demeure
maintenant dans la région mais encore
faut-il le démontrer montrer ses racines
du côté de l'estrie est aussi va
peut-être rappeler aux gens
effectivement que les
politiques surtout convaincre les
électeurs maintenant la brière est très
engagé aussi une chic et très aimée au
niveau des étudiants parce que madame
l'abri vont voir venez que s'il a quatre
ans trop fort erie vont faire ce qu'ils
veulent le parti québécois et le parti
vert ont déjà présenté leurs candidats
les candidatures des autres partis se
font encore attendre mais tout porte à
croire que ce sera un duel la caq contre
québec solidaire